so uh let me first introduce to you uh
dr evde kia and agnostic
uh i think uh evdekia exemplifies
one of the ways that breakthroughs are
going to occur in the sense that she is
a clinician
scientist and somebody who is involved
with the patients
but she brings the connection to the
basic science
uh to the table to to the patient
themselves
she's an assistant professor she's a
neurologist at the university of toronto
and at the bloorview research institute
and i'm proud to see that she's the lead
on the ontario brain institute funded a
program of ontario
in neurodevelopmental disorders which
they call pond which is this idea of
of connecting people across ontario to
investigate these neurodevelopmental
disorders
second is going to be mark dr marlis
sokolowski
marla is also typifies something which i
think is very important
this idea of bringing the basic science
but also the complexity of science
to the table she is a university
professor
and this is more than just a professor
this is the highest
designation that the university of
toronto bestows upon individuals she's
in the department
of ecology and evolutionary biology and
she's also the academic director of the
fraser institute
fraser muster institute of human
development and i will also say that the
two of them
are the ones who organized the entire
two and a half day symposium which gave
us a chance to bring together all of
these wonderful individuals from across
the world
to discuss in-depth the complexities and
the potential
for research in autism spectrum
disorders
and i'm going to turn first to have the
kiev
good evening everybody it's absolutely a
pleasure to be here today
and i have five minutes to uh
give you an idea a little bit about how
we're thinking
the new discoveries in genomics and
image and imaging and animal models and
neuropathology
have the potential finally to translate
into
meaningful new treatments so
this is our problem we have a common
disease
common disorder affects more than one
percent of the population more than one
percent of kids in the school system
right now
affects both their brains and their
bodies and we still don't have a single
medication
that treats autism why is that um
and it the truth is it's not it's not a
surprise
so we knew of autism spectrum disorder
as a disorder that
provides high social communication
difficulties and repetitive behaviors
but until recently we didn't know what
the biology was
and if we don't know the biology we
don't have a target
to develop a medication to treat the
underlying condition
what's particularly exciting and what
we've been discussing quite a bit at the
meeting and we're going to continue to
discuss tomorrow
is that this biology information is
coming through so as you just heard from
dr sher there is an explosion of
findings in genomics giving us
more than 100 potentially candidate
genes that may be involved in increasing
the risk for kids with autism
for to develop autism and at first it
may sound like a
difficult proposition to develop
treatments for a disease that has more
than 100 genes
but it turns out it's not that bad it
turns out that
we may have more than 100 genes but they
tend to map
into certain metabolic pathways so this
was an example
that was shown before if this is a
synapse which is a space between two
nerve cells to neurons
then there are multiple genes that
affect either structural elements of the
synapse
or part of the pathway that comes after
the postsynaptic membrane here
that are actually candida genes for
autism so although we have many many
genes
that seem to be producing some risk
conferring some risk for autism
it turns out that there may be a limited
number of pathways
that these drinks map onto and if that
is true
then we have a limited number of targets
to develop medications for
it's much it's becoming a much more
manageable problem
so so this is one story the second story
is
we're learning a lot from animal models
and some of that is at the same space as
the genomic findings so once a genomic
finding has come up
people can model that genomic finding in
the animal models
another kind of avenue that people have
followed is to actually
study the circuitries the animal circuit
the brain circuitries that are involved
in social communication and repetitive
behaviors
since these are the two areas we have
difficulty in autism
to study them in in the animal model and
see if we can understand its chemistry
and manipulate the chemistry so we can
find therapies
and i'll just take a quick example it's
not that we can argue if it's the best
example but it's one of the examples
this is a oxytocin which is a hormone
that's produced in our brains we all
have it
we used to think of it as a female
hormone because it's very important for
delivery and milk let down for women
turns out men have plenty of oxytocin in
their brains
they do not give birth and they do not
breastfeed babies so what's oxytocin
doing in their brains
turns out that if you take out the
oxytocin gene
you lose a lot of your social function
in the animal model so in this case it's
a it's a mouse experiment where
if you use typically developing let's
say mice
when you introduce a new mouse into the
litter they spend a certain amount of
time sniffing each other and getting to
know each other
but every time you reintroduce the mouse
into the liter they spend less and less
time because now they know this mouse
they don't need to sniff as much turns
out if you knock out the oxytocin gene
for example
every time you reintroduce the mouse in
the leader they act as if they've never
met this mouse before so they'll
lose part of what we call their social
recognition a finding that we also have
in autism
all right so if and these are just two
examples of the type of data that's
coming
out neuropathology studies also have
implicated immune responses and
a variety of other systems that we're
exploring so if that's what we're
learning
what can we do with it in terms of
developing new medications
well we have options now we have we
didn't have options before
what we used to do is assume that if a
symptom is present in autism and
in another disorder there must be
sharing biology and therefore we can
borrow drugs from other disorders and
test them in autism
well guess what happened some of them
actually worked but they didn't work for
the core symptoms of autism they didn't
work for the social communication the
repetitive behaviors
they worked for that symptom that we had
borrowed from the other disorder from
so for example if we borrowed a drug
from the adhd world
well it worked for adhd in kids with
autism
so we did not have a big impact in the
actual
core symptoms of autism we have now a
couple of options extra options
one is to target the genomic findings
the molecular targets that are coming
through this um
explosion of genomic research there are
lots and lots of examples
of areas we can work and i'm just going
to give you a grocery slide with just a
couple of those
but again this is your usual synapse and
again we can all debate about whether
these are good candidates or not
but there are plenty of targets in these
synapses that are
can be manipulated right now with
existing therapeutic agents
and these are drugs that are already
currently in clinical trials
either in kids with autism or in kids
who have other syndromes that are
associated with autism
to see whether we can actually
manipulate the social deficits and the
communication deficits and repetitive
behaviors
the other approach is to take the
circuitry knowledge the brain knowledge
that we are learning from the animal
models
and also develop therapeutics for those
for example in the case of oxytocin
remember this is the mouse that when
has no oxytocin loses its social
recognition
well the question is does the same thing
happen in human
turns out if you give people a stimulus
like this which is a set of ice and you
ask them to decide what is the
right emotion people who take
one dose of oxytocin are much more
accurate
in detecting the emotion than people who
take placebos
tastes the same feels the same but has
no active drug in it so if this is
happening in human humans then the
question is
is there room to manipulate this system
in people with autism or other disorders
who have social dysfunction
to actually um improve social function
this is another example and then i'll
skip to the last slide
this is the for those of you who are
families who have somebody in your
family with autism will appreciate this
turns out if you take college students
who have no problems and you give them
oxytocin or placebo
while they're watching faces people who
have no problem when they are on
oxytocin spend more items more time
looking at eyes
than mouth and non-social parts of the
picture
than if they are taking placebo so
oxytocin reorients you
to the social parts of the face
including the eyes which we know is an
issue for autism
so in this context there have been
multiple initiatives in ontario
and i want to highlight the ontario
brain institute pond initiative
um because of its serious kind of
size and commitment to fund uh
from basic science and genomics all the
way to clinical trials
so the idea here is we're taking autism
and other related disorders such as
adhd intellectual disability or
obsessive compulsive disorder
we're studying there that we invited the
families to come in
they can contribute genetic material we
can study their coding sequences on
their genes we can study the way the
genes
speak to their body or interact with the
environment we can image them and look
at their structure and the function
of their brain we can look at the
peripheral nervous system and see if
we can see we have markers for anxiety
and so on and then we can put them in
clinical trials and test all these
innovative compounds as they're coming
up the pipeline
and start figuring out what works and
what are the biological markers such as
genetics and imaging and so on that
predict response
so that we can start individualizing
treatments for kids with autism
based on their biology and i'm gonna
stop at that